what is your favorite NBA play of all
time James Harden Yanks Patrick Beverly
and then got it and one three and
pointed at him like Kyrie's three
against the Warriors 2016. that side
step against Golden State I was crazy
probably the best game probably the best
moment five step three to put him up
three I was fired side so
it Warriors versus OKC when uh
Steph pulled that shot when he was like
barely across half court
three feet I mean three steps past the
half court line LeBron he's running
throws it out to Kyrie he trips falls
gets up and Kyrie throws alive and you
don't think I when I was watching the
play live I didn't think LeBron was
going to get in all of a sudden he comes
up catches it and dunks it and I think
he falls again but that was one of my
favorite plays of all time oh Kobe
Bryant he threw it off the backboard one
time and he went and dunked it I liked
that yeah it was that you know I know
it's cold pressed to Marty Chalmers to
LeBron James dunk on the Jason that was
great